dimanche prochain notre journal régional
se fera les pieds dans l'eau en direct
de vallon pont d'arc à l'occasion de
l'épreuve marathon international de
canoë-kayak un sport qui se pratique
toute l'année sur l'ardèche mais pas sur
toute la rivière
d'où un programme d'aménagement depuis
dix ans connu sous le nom d' ardèche
claire attention obstacle à la
navigation depuis mai 89 un arrêté
préfectoral interdit le franchissement
des barrages par les pratiquants de
canoë kayak dans tout le département
il faut dire que 48% les accidents de
rivière sont dues au phénomène de
rappels produits par les barrages
la solution le portage les non
satisfaisante puisqu'elle empêche la
navigation en continu ou une autre
solution l'aménagement de glissières
pionniers l'ardèche a construit la
première en 80 depuis les passe à canoë
sont devenus une politique systématique
qui concilie valorisation du patrimoine
et production énergétique
nous pensons équipe et huit barrages
ce qui permettra d'avoir 40 km de
rivières praticable en été en toute
sécurité par les estivants se prendra
pas pu être réalisé si nous n'avions pas
à mener un complément de débit en
intimant important pendant la période
estivale également le deuxième aspect
c'est l'aspect qualité des eaux ou la
grand programme avait remis d'avoir
maintenant depuis trois ans une eau
d'excellente qualité tout à fait apte à
la baignade
les objectifs sont simples rendre la
rivière navigable toute l'année et au
delà de la réserve des gorges en 93 40
kilomètres supplémentaires de rivières
seront offerts aux kayakistes d'où un
total de près de 80 kilomètres
navigables beaucoup d'aménagements sont
en cours de réalisation comme à aubenas
où les travaux de restauration du
barrage devrait commencer avant l'hiver
des aménagements qui sont autant
d'atouts précieux pour le développement
d'une pratique de loisirs comme de haut
niveau